Chances are, you probably aren't overly eager
to lock lips with most of the people at your
job.
It's really no different for actors, but they
have to do it fairly often, and sometimes,
the results are as uncomfortable to watch
as they must have been to film.
While it's a bit weird that a kiss between
two teenage characters would be widely anticipated,
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows Part
2 is a franchise-concluding exception.
Hermione Granger and Ron Weasley's combative
relationship begins to soften ever so slightly
once they admit their romantic feelings for
each other.
After a particularly harrowing series of events
in which their survival is far from assured,
Hermione and Ron finally lock lips.
But rather than taking the audience deeper
into this intense moment and the terrifying
events that preceded it, their kiss is awkward
enough to have the audience looking away.
Talking to MTV News, Emma Watson confessed
that she and Rupert Grint were extremely uncomfortable
and nervous during filming, and Watson in
particular since it was her first proper onscreen
kiss.
"It was ones the only...it was honestly like
kissing my brother.
It was weird."
Silver Linings Playbook garnered a whole host
of awards season attention.
This quirky drama is about a mentally ill
man named Pat who is forced to move back in
with his parents after his marriage falls
apart.
While there, he gets caught up with manic
pixie dream girl Tiffany who manages to rope
him into being her dance partner for a ballroom
competition.
While their onscreen smooch did win an MTV
Movie Award for Best Kiss, their saliva swap
was as awkward to film as it was to watch.
On The Graham Norton Show, Cooper revealed
that Lawrence called him out on set for being
a bad kisser:
"After the second take [Lawrence] said, 'You're
a wet kisser.
You don't want to hear that.
It was not a compliment."
After proposing to his longtime girlfriend
Fat Amy, Bumper is unceremoniously and publicly
dumped by Amy, who claims she is far from
ready to stop playing the field, even though
in Pitch Perfect 2 and its predecessor, she's
only been interested in him.
They spend much of the movie apart until Amy
has an epiphany at a capella boot camp and
decides she really does love him and now wants
to change her final answer to a resounding
"yes."
To the tune of Pat Benatar's We Belong, sung
by Rebel Wilson and Adam DeVine, Bumper and
Amy reconnect in one of the most awkward kissing
scenes of the past decade, although this one's
definitely awkward on purpose.
As they weirdly lip-lock and roll around the
grass while also managing to keep singing,
the awkwardness just heightens the romantic
comedy ick factor.
Angelina Jolie is no stranger to being called
out for awkward onscreen kisses, which is
bizarre considering she's consistently named
one of the world's most beautiful women.
First it was her uncomfortable and passionless
lip-lock with James McAvoy in 2008's Wanted,
which was as awkward to film as it was to
watch.
But this past decade, she and co-star Johnny
Depp get the prize for lackluster kissing
scenes everyone expected to smolder.
Instead, their makeout sessions are about
as spicy as a boiled potato, and Depp told
the Mirror that he was uncomfortable filming
the scenes and had to use humor to get through
them.
It just goes to show that just because a movie
casts two gorgeous leads doesn't mean there
will be onscreen chemistry.
"What an awkward situation."
As the dinosaurs take over once again in Jurassic
World, a lot of questionable things go down.
First, they've made a hybrid dinosaur from
recombinant DNA that is not only majorly aggressive,
but its chameleon traits allow it to fully
blend into any surroundings.
Second, as Claire, Owen, and her nephews are
being hunted by dinosaurs, Claire and Owen
share an awkward lip lock that is completely
out of place.
Yes, there are indeed times in life when a
well-timed kiss even amid inappropriate circumstances
can help to relieve tension, whether in real
life or onscreen.
But the jury is still out on whether this
applies to being under attack from hordes
of dinosaurs.
Funnily enough, according to Jurassic World's
leading lady, the kiss was unscripted and
spontaneous, which only makes it worse that
it came off so awkward.
Tate Taylor's revenge horror movie Ma features
Octavia Spencer as Sue Ann Ellington, a veterinary
assistant in a small American town.
After a group of high school kids headed by
Andy Hawkins asks Sue Ann to buy liquor for
them, she realizes that these are the children
of her own high school bullies, and she begins
concocting an elaborate plan to get back at
the people who most badly hurt her.
As Sue Ann rampages her way through her list
of offenders, she ends up kissing young Andy,
who is attempting to placate her more violent
impulses.
Unlike many of the awkward kisses of the last
decade, this scene is orchestrated to creepy
effect on purpose, highlighting Sue Ann's
post-traumatic psychosis as well as how far
the teens will go in order to survive.
The Jennifer Lawrence and Chris Pratt sci-fi
drama Passengers doesn't only feature one
of the most awkward kissing scenes of the
past decade, it's also arguably one of the
most uncomfortable movies of the decade to
boot with an incredibly problematic plot.
Pratt plays Jim, a passenger on a space colony
ship who wakes up decades early during the
voyage.
He sees another passenger, Aurora, whom he
falls in love with and decides to wake her
up so he won't be alone anymore.
He does this despite the fact that doing so
will doom her to a lonely life and death on
the ship along with him.
Yikes.
It's a while before Aurora finds out her awakening
wasn't an accident like Jim's, at which point
they've already begun a relationship that
includes physical intimacy.
Passengers was Jennifer Lawrence's first sex
scene, as well as her first time kissing a
married co-star.
She was so uncomfortable with the scenario
that she said she ended up getting drunk to
film their scenes, which only made the situation
even more awkward to film and to watch.
"Don't eat that, no…That's not what you..."
Shailene Woodley isn't only known for her
strong performances in films like the Divergent
series as well as HBO's Big Little Lies.
She's also known to be really into holistic
therapies, Chinese medicine, and clean eating.
You'd think her healthy lifestyle would make
her an optimal kissing partner, but her The
Spectacular Now co-star Miles Teller has a
different perspective.
Talking to Variety, Teller recalled,
"Before our first kissing scene, Shailene
took these Chinese dirt supplements and shoved
them in her mouth.
It's like a dirt pouch, and it smells like
crap...She always has a mason jar and 100%
of the time it smells like crap."
"I, I had some this morning, so you might
be like, 'Shay, stay away, because you have
fire dragon breath.'"
Luckily for Teller, most of their kissing
scenes were in the middle of fraught and complicated
situations, so he didn't necessarily need
to look like he was fully enjoying things.
After several bombs, master of the twist ending
M. Night Shyamalan returned in 2016 with the
multiple personality horror movie Split.
James McAvoy plays Kevin Wendell Crumb, a
man so traumatized by the abuse he survived
as a child he has created an entire army of
alternate personalities that help him cope.
These personalities have begun to merge into
the Horde and the Beast, a violent being who
defies the laws of nature.
The Horde has kidnapped three high school
girls, including Casey Cooke, and is keeping
them prisoner for the Beast's next meal.
One of Kevin's alters is nine-year-old Hedwig,
who Casey manages to bond with and almost
allows her to escape.
In the process, Hedwig asks if he can kiss
Casey, who has no choice but to comply.
The result is one of the most awkward kisses
ever, let alone the past decade.
There is still so much that is unclear about
the sixth installment of the Alien franchise.
Set years after the future events depicted
in Prometheus, Alien: Covenant finds the android
David after he's fashioned himself a kingdom
on the home planet of humanity's creators,
called the Engineers.
David lures a colony ship on their way to
terraform a new planet to his home on Paradise,
where he meets Walter, a new android model
who looks just like David.
David shows Walter his creepy lair, covered
in sketches of the Xenomorph creature, jars
filled with all kinds of weird stuff, and
a variety of tools and instruments that David
has been creating or repurposing.
After teaching Walter how to play the flute,
David kisses Walter full on the mouth.
Why he does this is never explained (maybe
an expression of pure narcissism to kiss his
identical twin?) but it is as awkward as awkward
gets, made worse by the fact that David tries
to kill Walter almost immediately after.
Reese Witherspoon had a decidedly unpleasant
experience on the set of her carnival period
piece Water for Elephants with co-star Robert
Pattinson.
This romantic drama stars Pattinson as Jacob,
a veterinary student who drops out of school
to join the Benzini Brothers Circus.
There Jacob meets Witherspoon's Marlena and
her abusive partner, the big top ringmaster
August.
He can't help but fall in love with this beautiful
but damaged woman even though August's temper
would put them all in danger if he ever found
out.
During one of their kissing scenes, the music
swells in elaborate and emotional waves, but
Pattinson later totally ruined the moment
in an interview with MTV, saying:
"I was doing it when I had a really bad cold.
My nose is running all over the place, and
it was in one of the additional photography
scenes, and Reese had this wig on, and literally,
I was wiping my nose on her wig."
Witherspoon corroborated his story, saying,
"He did have a very runny nose, yeah.
It wasn't appealing; it wasn't pleasant."
There's nothing like implied incest to make
any situation awkward.
In We're the Millers, drug dealer David Clark
has to smuggle an RV full of marijuana across
the border and needs a cover family to help.
He enlists dancer Sarah Rose to be his pretend
wife, and runaway Casey and his neighbor Kenny
to round out the fake family.
On the way they link up with another family,
and Kenny starts crushing on their daughter
Melissa.
Kenny wants to make a move but doesn't know
how to kiss, so Casey and Sarah Rose give
him a detailed tutorial.
Of course Melissa walks in on them, horrified,
not realizing that these folks aren't actually
family at all.
Awkward!
Since this reveal potentially threatens their
cover story, more hijinks ensue for "The Millers."
According to actor Will Poulter, the scene
was as awkward to film as it was to watch.
By the close of Avengers: Endgame, the decades-long
love affair between Captain America, a.k.a.
Steve Rogers, and Peggy Carter ends up taking
on new prominence as the Avengers undo Thanos'
murderous snap.
It was undeniable how much Cap loved Peggy,
but Captain America: Civil War features an
unintentionally awkward kiss between Cap and
Peggy's great-niece Sharon Carter, which takes
place after they've both attended Peggy's
funeral.
Peggy Carter actress Hayley Atwell herself
told Entertainment Weekly,
"I wouldn't want to date my great aunt's guy.
It just feels like it crosses an incestuous
boundary.
And Peggy just died.
That's even more disrespectful, right?
It's like, 'Don't touch that.
You can't tap that!'"
Not only does Atwell have an excellent point,
Chris Evans and Emily VanCamp also had questionable
onscreen chemistry that made a problematic
kiss even more awkward to watch.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.